que s'est-il passé dans ce cabinet
dentaire du quartier des fontaines à
Tours à cette heure peu d'informations
encore ce que l'on sait c'est qu'un
patient mécontent d'une consultation a
fait irruption avant de poignarder à
plusieurs reprises le dentiste et son
assistante l'auteur présumé des faits
était arrêté le point sur place avec
Hélène chapelet
l'effet ce serait déroulé ici en début
d'après-midi dans le cabinet dentaire
situé juste derrière moi nous sommes
dans le quartier des fontaines à Tours
selon une source proche du dossier un
ancien patient serait venu pour se
plaindre d'une opération qu'il a subi il
y a quelques jours le procureur de la
République que nous avons croisé c'est
donc rendu sur place dans l'après-midi
pour essayer de comprendre les motifs de
cette agression
selon les premiers éléments de l'enquête
l'individu de 41 ans ce serait précipité
sur le dentiste de 58 ans et lui aurait
porté de nombreux coups de couteau son
assistante qui est intervenue a
également été blessé de victimes dont
les pronostics vitaux ne sont pas
engagés mais qui sont sérieusement
blessés l'individu qui a finalement été
maîtrisée à l'intérieur du cabinet
médical n'est pas connu des services de
police ou de justice son état de santé
n'a pour l'instant pas été jugé
compatible avec une garde à vue
l'audition des témoins doit se
poursuivre dans la soirée